this is an idea that i think i mentioned
just sort of
as a passing comment um when we're
looking at the sum of a gp
okay um so let's revise that let's
remember you've got a geometric series
you have a common ratio
what is the sum of the first in terms
can we remember it's the fraction b
yeah we start with the first term right
and then we um
we multiply by the ratio we're going to
multiply the whole series by the ratio
and then we subtracted it so we've got
two different versions of this do you
remember
this one that's one fraction
which is that's actually the same as if
we reverse
the numerator okay all right now
um i sort of alluded but i didn't really
go into the um
uh the fact that if you take a ratio
that's that's smaller than one right so
we've been thinking about
if if ratios get bigger like say if the
common ratio is two
sorry not if the ratios get bigger if
the terms get bigger
this thing will just spiral off and get
huge right and the more terms you take
the bigger it gets
okay but if we pick some ratio that's
smaller than one like say a half
and we talked about the frog right
that this even though it has an infinite
set of terms
the actual sum if we took is a finite
thing which is strange
um infinite objects add up to a finite
actual value okay so how do we work that
out
let's think about let's imagine if i
actually can take
the sum of not the first n terms but all
of the terms how would you write that
i suppose you could probably um say the
sum
to infinity right so some people you'll
sometimes see this notation
but that's kind of weird because
infinity it's not really
a number and the maths that we have for
dealing with infinities
plural because there are different kinds
of infinite it's not very well developed
especially
so when you see just an s on its own
without any number down here okay that's
actually taking the sum of
all the terms
okay all the terms now let's just
consider
what happens when r this common ratio
is smaller than one so i'm trying to
work this out so i'm going to come over
here for a second
if the ratio is less than one
okay and i suppose i should probably
also say
it's greater than negative one because
ratios can be negative
right like i could have a ratio of minus
five and that would go
you know one minus five plus 25
minus 125 you get the idea still follows
the same rules
so i'll have this boundary sometimes
you'll see that written as
the absolute value of r is less than one
can you see how they're actually the
same thing because the absolute value
says make it
positive all right if that's the
condition we're putting on r
what happens
to this guy out of the m uh and we're
considering
actually i'm going to introduce we're
considering as m gets bigger and bigger
and bigger
now rather than saying as n gets bigger
and bigger and bigger we have language
actually
from calculus to talk about when things
get insanely big
right we call them limits so what limits
should i take
as as n gets really really big so that's
n to infinity right
what happens to this again if
r is between these boundaries well just
as an example
right suppose we took this value r as a
half right
well it's going to get
sorry that's smaller and smaller and
smaller right in fact as
n approaches infinity what does this
thing approach
it approaches zero doesn't it gets
smaller and smaller as well
now a half that gets small sorry over
here that gets more pretty quick
doesn't it okay but if you take
something that's even
quite close to one like say 99 over 100
okay it's close to one but because it's
still smaller than one every time you
multiply and if i'm doing it
off to infinity right it's still
actually going to be equal to zero
is that okay we're content with this
idea it's weird um
because we're not actually getting to
infinity but the idea that it gets
smaller
once more is the important part okay
therefore
what's happening to this sum over here
here's one of the cases where
i'm going to go for the right hand side
what happens to
r to the n sorry this out at the end
as n approaches infinity it becomes zero
so i don't have to worry about it
right does that make sense it becomes
so is inconsequentially small that i can
forget about
so therefore i'm left with a times 1
which is just
a right divided by
1 minus r now that r doesn't disappear
because it's just one of them so that'll
be 1 minus a half
or 1 minus 99 over 100 or whatever okay
so so this this is what we call
the limiting sum okay that if you've got
this condition here your ratios in
between with negative one and one
this is what the whole thing will
approach okay now
i told you before that like integration
um
this topic explains some results that
you learned a long time ago
but we didn't have the equipment to
explain why so
here's what i'm going to take um i'm
going to give you a decimal and i want
you
to give me a fraction that actually
expresses that decimal okay so let's
start off easily
what's that equal to or that's a quarter
right
what about say let's go for
0.2 what's that
okay now if i were to give you
0.3 and
make it a repeater okay so this is 13 33
now i'm gonna know forever
what fraction is that equal to a third
right hold on a second these these we
understand
but but why is this the case why can't
it go through and you know other
examples right this is not the only one
if i say 0.1 what's that equal to
1 over 9 okay and you could verify this
in your calculator let's go let's go
another step
further what about say 0.15
repeat up so one five one five one point
four zero this is year seven
this is a what do we call these these
have a name they're called
their decimal values and they recur they
can't they go again again so we call
them
recurring decimals what's it equal to
remember
get your calculator out and for some
reason it's 15 or 99
okay so you're like but but why is that
okay you can
learn this result we make you learn it
in year seven but can you explain it
i wonder if the um if the chords are
turning in your head yet
uh these three here
even though they don't look like it
they're gps
what's going on uh these are geometric
progressions
it's actually the sum the whole thing
how can i make that a little more
obvious well
let's go after this one let me let me
rub this off
zero point one five one five one five
one five and so on
if i were to make this into a we'll try
and rewrite it as a geometric
progression
an infinite one because it goes on
forever right what would the terms be
well um the repeating part is the
pattern after right so there's one
five there and there's another one what
it is equal to if i were to say put it
in
as a fraction it might be a little more
obvious okay this first 0.15
if i made a fraction would be 15 over
100
is that okay 15 yeah what's the next one
equal to just just that one on its own
0.0015
to get two more zeros i've got to add
them onto the denominator right
two more zeros about the next one well i
just add
two more zeros again right
two four six and so on
okay can you see the gp
let me make it a little more obvious
again this is 15 over 100 to the power
of one
right the next one is 15 over 100
squared that i added two more zeros and
the last one well
the last one i've written anyway is
okay now can we can we put this together
now
what's the first term that's the first
term
right a is equal to 15 over 100.
what's the common ratio what am i
multiplying by
to go from 10 to 10 um it's getting 100
times smaller
right so the ratio is 1 over 100
okay now these a and r they're the only
two pieces i need for the limiting sum
okay so i would say this whole thing
0.15
repeater that's my my s if you like
is equal to a over 1 minus
r okay this is just straight
substitution yeah
15 over 100 divided by
one minus one over is that okay there's
my a and my r
what happens on the bottom i've got 15
over 100
just watch out with your fractions and
fractions 1 minus 1
over 100 is 99 over 100 right
and you've got a common factor there on
the numerator and the denominator
which you can get rid of
and there's our magic number
okay so and you can you can simplify
this of course uh let's see
divide by three so five over
that's enough isn't it okay so there you
go now
recurring decimals if you said to
yourself oh yes the reason why this is
the recurring decimal was because the
geometric position of course wouldn't
make sense right
but now you've got the pieces to make
sense of that okay